[Music]
the Fairchild Republic A10 lightning
bolt or simply the hog is one of the
most iconic planes in the US Air Force
the G8 Avenger is a monstrous machine
designed to wreck havoc on those Soviet
tanks attempting to push through Allied
lines the gun takes up a significant
portion of the plane internal volume at
nearly 6 M long fitting snugly below the
pilot The Recoil Force at 44.5 kons is
so powerful that it effectively hals the
plan's forward thrust as each of the
a10s General Electric t34 engines
produces just 41 kons of thrust but the
plane fires in such short bursts
typically 1 to two seconds that the
pilot doesn't need to worry about
salling